un séisme sous-marin de magnitude 9 puis
une vague de 23 mètres de haut qui
s'écrase sur la côte nord-est du japon
emportant tout sur son passage
le bilan humain est lourd près de 20000
morts et 2500 disparu les villes sont
dévastés 165 mille habitants sont
déplacés au tsunami succès d'un accident
nucléaire qui donnera son nom à
l'événement
la catastrophe de fukushima à 12
kilomètres de la ville une centrale
nucléaire est inondée par la vague
provoquant une fusion partielle des
coeurs des réacteurs
s'ensuit une explosion libérant des
substances radioactives dans
l'atmosphère laissant craindre une
intoxication des populations des terres
et des eaux commence alors une vaste
opération de décontamination les caméras
du monde entier sont braqués sur les 50
de fukushima ses employés de la centrale
restait sur place malgré l'exposition
aux radiations
dix ans plus tard les travaux de
nettoyage se poursuivent
des montagnes de terres radioactives ont
été stockés près de fukushima à titre
provisoire mais au moins jusqu'en 2045
le temps de trouver une structure pour
les isoler à ce jour 15 % de la zone à
décontaminer ont été nettoyés le
démantèlement de la centrale pourrait
lui prendre encore 30 à 40 ans les
anti-nucléaires japonais manifestent
contre la lenteur et l'opacité des
opérations notamment à l' approche des
jeux olympiques de tokyo prévue cet été
je veux que la centrale touchés par la
crise soient mises hors service plus
rapidement mais on ne sait pas quand
elle le sera enfin j'ai vraiment peur
que plusieurs réacteurs soient encore
exploités je veux que les réacteurs
endommagés soit pris en charge le plus
rapidement possible nous les japonais ne
savons toujours pas comment se fait le
déplacement
je suis très déçu je ne pense pas du
tout que les habitants de fukushima
crois que les choses olympique aideront
à la reconstruction le gouvernement nous
impose cette idée en disant que ce
seront les jeux olympiques de la
reconstruction et que la centrale
nucléaire de fukushima est sous contrôle
ce n'est pas vrai je crains que le site
n'explose si une catastrophe se produit
à nouveau si les craintes pour la santé
publique demeure quant aux conséquences
de l'explosion de la centrale nucléaire
un rapport scientifique sur ses
répercussions sur la population et
l'environnement publié ce mercredi par
le comité scientifique des nations unies
pour l'étude des effets des rayonnements
ionisants conclu en revanche à l'absence
de suite directe
selon cette étude les rejets radioactifs
emportée par le vent n'aurait pas touché
terre sur près de 25 mille salariés de
la centrale
seuls six auraient reçu une dose de
radioactivité supérieurs à 250
millisieverts tu doses équivalentes à
celles subies par les pompiers mobilisés
autour de la centrale de tchernobyl en
ukraine
les habitants eux auraient été soumis à
des doses plus faibles
toujours selon ce rapport ce drame a
bien eu des retombées environnementales
causées par les gigantesques opérations
de décontamination